you know um last time i saw you was
underneath the grammy stage you know and
you and your sister were kind of like
trying to digest it all
during that crazy like photo tunnel yeah
yeah wild
what do you remember about that night in
that moment and how it
was like life-changing yeah the further
from that night i get like the more i
think and i've heard other people say
this i just read some
autobiography where they said this where
like you start to only remember the
videos and photos you've seen
yeah and you don't remember like
actually what it felt like to be in your
body for something
if it's like well documented so more and
more i'm like detached from it it feels
like somebody else but
nevertheless it was like a peak life
experience and it it felt like that the
whole time i was living through it now
it feels like looking at
somebody else's family photos or
something that's hilarious um
and also you and your sister kind of
shared your life i mean you
really opened up your life like
everybody's watching it now and
everybody's like
they're commenting on your life right is
that strange totally yeah
i mean reviewing a song that uh
you've written about you know something
you lived through
or maybe something that you didn't you
just made up is one thing you're
reviewing like a piece of art but like
essentially like reviewing our
households and like our yes
relationship with our mom and dad so
it's very strange um we're lucky
everybody's been
super nice and there's been a lot of
support thrown at our
parents which has been uh very sweet and
an honor because we love them
so much yeah yeah to see them get some
more love it's been really sweet
and duck is great i mean i think it's
it's a great peek into life changing but
people staying normal
it's as normal as they can right i mean
i think the
main thing and i i assume this probably
is represented in the dark is that
actually
within the circle of like our family
like
not much changed right so we didn't have
to right
go through that sort of internal change
everything kind of on a surface level
changed around billy and you know me as
a
side effect but like yeah on the kind of
insular level with our relationship with
our mom and dad and me and
uh billy and her friend zoe who's in a
lot of the doctors like you know it's
very sort of like insular which is nice
hey um newmie music your new music and
what was it like making your
your music um uh it was really f
the last project that i put out as like
a body of work was in
october 2019 but then i put out several
songs
in 2020 that were very sort of like
retrospective about
2020 i was just sort of processing how i
was feeling about
this crazy past year in my writing so a
lot of those songs
reflect that very directly with like
what they'll say about us or um
can't wait to be dead and so i think in
moving forward it's probably
getting back to a slightly more like
introspective
space just because like i think i i've
written
i've written my way through that sort of
observational period so it's kind of
more
general now where do you keep your
grammys i keep them on this shelf
in my living room that's too high for my
dog to knock them over
but i don't i just we just won this
other one i
was like i don't know where to put that
one because that shelf is maxed out
so i don't want to put it is it weird
that you i mean you have a lot of
grammys dude
yeah yeah we had uh jamila jamil over at
some point like
pre-covet or something and she was like
oh you have so many grammys she's like
that's really quite a lot
like um yes so it's an embarrassing
amount
but it's an honor